la grève s'étend dans les universités
elle commence à gagner les lycées et
elle prend l'alluré d'une levée de
boucliers contre la loi devaquet de
réforme des universités ce qui inquiète
plus les étudiants et futurs étudiants
la sélection les droits d'inscription
est le fait que chaque université pourra
créer ses propres diplômes la grève
gagne du terrain même si elle n'est pas
suivie partout de la même façon avant
d'en parler avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale rené monory l'état
des lieux à longèves parti lentement la
semaine dernière de l'université de
villetaneuse près de paris le mouvement
de grève touche ce soir la quasi
totalité des universités de la région
parisienne en province la grève gagne du
terrain mais de façon sporadique
ici à rennes la grève a été votée à main
levée dans l'amphithéâtre l'être mais
les sciences n'ont pas rejoint le
mouvement même démarrage très progressif
à toulouse aix marseille nancy et reims
d'une façon générale le mouvement est
plus suivi en lettres conscience et en
droit c'est à lyon que la situation est
le plus contrastée lyon a et 2 se dirige
vers la grève alors qu'ici à lyon 3 les
cours continuent comme ailleurs les
discussions sont plutôt houleuse entre
grévistes et non grévistes
on va bien ce beaucoup de gens penseront
que c'est plus la fac parce que c'est
totalement démocratique effectivement si
une sélection à l'entrée mais de toute
façon la sélection la faculté elle se
fait parce qu'il ya énormément de
premières années il ya des effectifs qui
sont complètement faramineux et la
sélection se fait soit en fin de
première année sont fans deuxième année
malgré ces dissensions la grève pourrait
s'étendre encore demain ici à nancy
comme à montpellier à brest les cours
ont été interrompus aujourd'hui et les
étudiants se réuniront demain en
assemblée générale en résumé un
mouvement à la fois rapide et inégale
qui veut rester en dehors des structures
syndicales et politiques le gouvernement
dissout saint affricaine partenariat
constant au service d'oubli
l'enseignement supérieur un mouvement
commence aussi à se dessiner chez les
lycéens qui ont manifesté comme ici à
amiens la mobilisation devrait durer au
moins jusqu'au 27 novembre jour de
l'examen du projet devaquet par
l'assemblée nationale